welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that spends
too much time watching a trailer in
super slow motion to see how many
buttons are on america's shawvis's flag
jacket not enough buttons i've got to
get my cosplay right for the next con
after the apocalypse so i need to know
how many buttons are on that dang jacket
my name is mt and i'm here today with my
brother off-screen producer brandon
what's going on brandon hey mt how you
doing look they gave me a blue dungeon
can you believe it what a what a scale
you are in the void oh you fell into the
blue abyss welcome i like it here it's
very nice the water's delicious it's
good tasting water that's always a big
thing it's blue water it's everything
tastes like blue gatorade it's delicious
all right what's our big question for
today brandon well mt i mean you talked
about it you know
uh we got to talk about this dr strange
trailer right it's crazy we know what
the super bowl is all about it's the
commercials okay and sometimes buried in
those commercials we get some sweet
sweet trailers and this year certainly
just didn't disappoint they gave us a
couple good trailers it was great
but most importantly we got that brand
new dr strange in the multiverse of
madness trailer and in that trailer we
got to see some brand new variants of
doctor strange there we haven't seen yet
and that all leads us to this week's big
question
who are all the doctor strangers in the
multiverse of madness who are they moon
strangers strange eye too many strangers
going on in here what's going on
stranger danger stranger danger indeed
that's what mourinho says he's like hey
the more stranger we get the more danger
we get i that's a line from the movie
kevin feige texted me he told me yeah we
should put that on her shirt i like that
i like that i like it yo we should
really put that on a shirt that'd be
really fun let's get on it shirt people
but yeah we're going to do something
similar to what we did for all the
spider-man looks in the no way home
trailer i mean we were so right about
all those predictions so why not do it
again because we're on a roll we nailed
it nothing we said was wrong don't go
back and watch the video we we uh cast
the runes of call spell um so you don't
have to
go back to watch it because your
memories have been wiped uh but as you
watch this trailer for the 40th or 50th
or 60th millionth time like us you too
will begin to see all the strange
variations of steven strange's appearing
in this doctor strange trailer so let's
break them down and see if we can't
decipher how these strange variants will
interact in the upcoming film that's
going to be a banger first we have what
we call the standard strange look this
is the same uniform he's basically been
wearing when he became the sorcerer
supreme in the mcu and even appears to
keep after he's been blipped and demoted
to you know
a sorcerer supreme intern um intern
supreme sorcerer less supreme sorcerer
taco supreme if you know what i mean i
don't know what that means i love how
you're like if you know what i mean and
you go like i don't know what it means i
don't know what i mean i thought i don't
know what i'm saying well yeah it's the
blue tunic i have agamoto local
levitation ensemble that we've come to
know and love it's the classic steven
his hair and goatee are also in the
familiar style one slight thing to note
here a couple of times when his back is
turned we see a blue patch on the cloak
of levitation it's hard to say what this
could mean right now and every time we
see this patch on the cloak in the
trailer steven does appear to be in a
distorted reality either staring at this
ghostly sanctum or watching new york
dissolve away which is not very great
for the streets of new york but
but could the cloak have been damaged
and is this some sort of transformative
symbol on the cloak like what do you
think would be going on here with this
blue symbol yeah that blue patch is
really interesting because it it it
doesn't look like a fix necessarily we
don't really get a good look of its full
shape but if you were gonna like fix the
cloak of levitation
why would you use like a blue patch for
no reason and it's not been there before
i mean we've seen this cloak like you
said he's kind of had the same costume
uniform for his whole run in the mcu
some little changes here and there a
little little nicer fabric or a little
glow up on the on the gauntlets or
something but for the most part he's had
like the same outfit which is very weird
for the mcu also right every time they
got to have like a new uniform even
captain america every time we saw him he
got like a little bit of change got to
sell them toys you know what i'm talking
about kevin feige exactly you gotta have
you gotta change it up a little bit to
sell those action figures yeah but like
dr strange outfit has like never really
changed even yeah even after he became
the source supreme and lost that title
he still has like the same outfit so why
is there like a blue patch on the back
but you know as you pointed out every
time we see it it's not like he's on
a normal place he's in like a weird area
so is it like when he's in a different
dimension the cloak changes a little bit
i can't think of any permanent damage
that the cloak has had certainly not in
far from or no way home where we last
saw him
uh and i don't think there was anything
like in the what if episodes that like
damaged the cloak
uh to a point where it's like
really
really destroyed maybe
i mean the last time we saw the cloak
was on ned right for the for the most
part and he's like just floating down
the pogo is always like saving other
people it's like i gotta get to deal
with these other people who get in the
way but yeah for the most part
he's the same guy right this looks like
our steven strange as we know him but i
what is that blue patch all about i
think i think the cloak gets damaged
somehow early on and like he has to like
fix it and
he only has blue fabric laying around i
don't know i like to think that there's
like a flex tape wizard that just gives
him like a magic flex tape to fix the
the fixed version or maybe maybe it's
like a style you know those things where
you feel like you put a tile on your
keys and if you lose them you can track
them down maybe it's like a tile he puts
on so that when he goes into this weird
inky dimension or this dark dimension
they have a way of like pulling them
back they can track them through it or
something i don't know maybe maybe it's
like something that like america chavez
can maybe hone in on oh she's like all
right i'm gonna leave you here i'll be
back and then she'll just pops out
another reality it's like all right i
have the little tag here i know where
you are
but like no i think it it could be some
type of a magical relic of some sort
that is protecting him um from these
dark forces that are obviously in play
in this movie um and you know i think
that once he does come in contact with
the you know those technical creatures
um that appear to be you know gargantos
as we if we know from um
promo material or whatever um you know i
feel like he's probably gonna find out
that these darker creatures are stronger
than um
you know the these light magicians other
than the mcu can handle so he might need
some extra protection that comes in the
form of um this little blue thing that
that is
he's so dumb he's like christine i need
help
can you sew this up
i tore my cloak
he's a baby
the family of reality is broken
christine she's like you're a surgeon
you know how to sew just fix it
yeah i really hope that there is a
christine
like sorcerer supreme out there because
there has to be at some point because
she would be great uh because she's
always fixing his messes anyway i think
there is i think there is and i think we
saw her in the trailer
that would be interesting
but moving on we have a garden doctor
strange that we see in the trailer when
we see strange chatting with wanda in
the garden or orchard he appears to be
in a more casual blue jacket with a
scarf because it's a little bit chilly
yeah no cloak in sight which is kind of
interesting so this is probably still
the standard doctor strange but it's
interesting that he would chat with
wanda without his cloak could this
conversation be happening outside our
realm hmm that's an interesting idea
empty i mean there is that shot of them
talking and there's another shot later
in the trailer that almost has the same
framing but there's like red everywhere
and she's in her crown
and there's like it looks like a dead
tree behind him so it makes me think
when they're having that conversation
like it's in like maybe one of her weird
hexes
like when doctor strange showed up like
all of his you know in the hecks and and
westview people's clothes would change
like maybe all his clothes changed until
like this more casual
orchard appropriate attire where he
doesn't have his cape and his ayah
bogamoto because she doesn't want to see
all that no matter
you gotta match the aesthetic all right
there's a theme going on
we're still doing one division we're
still doing the one division stuff okay
uh because he is wearing like
it still has like a very uh mystical
look to it it's not just like a blue
shirt it's like a blue
tunicky kind of thing with like a nice
scarf but yeah why would he show up
to deal with wanda who he knows is like
a big big time in it now without like
his cloak and without his eye of
agamotto or whatever is inside of the
agamotto we don't even know uh why would
he show up without like his weapons per
se uh so it makes me think like he's in
a hex of some sort when he's talking to
her right there for sure because like
when when he shows up um one uh assumes
that he's there to basically magic
arrest her and be like uh here could he
yeah for one division oh so whoops she
was like here comes the magic cops
always always bugging me but uh maybe he
showed up without the cloak because of
that it's like i don't want to think of
we're about to throw down i'ma leave my
my flying cape on this okay just like
it's like holster putting your gun away
it's like hey i'm unarmed even though
i'm constantly armed i don't have any
weapons on me
okay i take that back i took the badge
off okay i'm not the sorcerer supreme
and she was like i know you're not the
sort of supreme he's like shut up no i
really like the idea of it's sort of
like being a mini wanda vision scenario
where strange approaches in his normal
attire and one is like
like him as soon as he approaches that
area of effect his his clothes change
he's like oh no i'm in the autumn land
now without with with wanda but yeah i
think you're right that that's still
that's still standard strange it's not a
variant this is still mcu strange
uh talking to wanda now let's talk about
blue strange because this is when we see
stephen at one of the most exciting
moments in the trailer he's been brought
in in shackles before what we assume to
be the mcu illuminati he's wearing a
fully blue ensemble with no cloak or eye
of agamotto or other apparent magical
devices and while doctor strange does
usually wear a blue outfit under his
cloak this one seems to look very
different and sort of like futuristic so
the big question here remains
is this our doctor strange or some type
of other variant i think and this might
be wild i think this is a different
doctor strange i don't think it is our
doctor's oh
cause you're right i don't think it's
the okay yeah
this guy is wearing a blue outfit but
it's very different and like i don't
know why they would like change his
clothes for him or whatever but i think
this could be a different doctor strange
like a variant and this doctor strange
gets to learn about the illuminati but
ours never does because i've said this
before on this channel and i still
believe it i think our doctor strange is
the bad doctor strange and he gonna die
and they're gonna replace him with like
a nicer doctor strange who hasn't messed
up the universe so much yeah that would
be bananas i would love to if our doctor
strange where to become a villain
because it's like no one is
like above becoming a villain yeah and i
think that it would sort of
underscore
how special it is for these heroes to
stay heroes like despite all of this
power that they're given because like
power can corrupt anyone really so i
would love if this lesson was this movie
was a lesson in just like controlling
your power or like um you know not
wanting too much power because as we see
in the trailer wong is like you can't
control everything strange like i know
you're obsessed with that knowing
knowledge and protecting everyone but
like you're gonna break if you try
to protect everyone so
chill out
so yeah empty do you think that
this blue strange is our doctor strange
you think this is our guy our mcu
strange
[Music]
i think that it is our um doctor strange
because of how monumental this whole
patrick stewart a professor x moment is
and um it just it would be super
impactful for our doctor strange to um
be talking to
the just professor x because we've been
wanting that mcu crossover with the fox
universe so i think that when that
happens and we do get that reveal i
think that marvel studios would want our
original recipe doctor strange to be
listening to
uh these gods of the marvel live-action
universe probably it's also possible
that this could be you know the raimi
strange that was teased uh in spider-man
oh my god i would love that i think
we're gonna see him like his own version
of strange yeah i think we're gonna see
the raymond
in this movie for sure i would love if
raymie strange was like the secret
villain of this it's like i'm from the
spanish man universe i'm really strange
i'm too strange i was in the marvel
first do you understand they never put
me on camera they cut me out i only got
my day rate i didn't get full payments
they cut my scenes that jameson
said by name didn't even pay me a
classic jameson but then of course we've
got evil doctor strange or some people
think is strange supreme from what if
like talking to who we assume is our
doctor strange in some of the same
footage we saw from the initial trailer
now this is clearly a variant of the mcu
doctor strange but have your feelings on
who this doctor strange is changed at
all mr brandon uh you know the more i s
it's interesting that they showed this
again the same footage no new footage of
this guy which makes me think this is
the only time we're gonna see this guy
in the movie
uh and i don't think i don't think it's
the same one from the what if universe i
just think it's they're gonna use this
one as a device to show
how different strangers can be and what
the extreme version could be but i think
that this evil doctor strange or like
strange supreme or however you think he
is i don't i think this is all we see
this guy and they're using it in the
trailer as like a mcguffin this guy
never leaves this room he just hangs out
and like when the ghost of future
present or whoever is taking strange
along this journey he's like this see
this is what can happen to you too
stephen strange if you don't get your
act together you'll be like this crazy
green skinned monster uh yeah
together ebenezer strange right right
yeah i think
this guy is like he's definitely a
variant of a strain of doctor strange
but he's this is all we see of this
character i bet and like this is they're
totally leading us down this path to
make us think this is the main villain
of this movie but it's it's really not i
don't think it is at all that would be
really interesting i think that
you're i do agree with you in the sense
that like i don't think this guy is
going to be the main villain i think
that there is going to be this a huge
like oh you thought and then here's a
secret villain i think that he's going
to be not a great force and i think that
he's going to be someone that's going to
be helping um doctor strange and friends
reluctantly yeah but like i think yeah i
think i think that he's he's going to
just be either taking
eliminated or just set up to the side
for a future
marvel movie if this i just don't think
that there's much
if this was a series and not a movie
they would do an episode where this the
evil strange got swapped with regular
strange and is like walking around new
york and like everyone who knows doctor
strange is like hey dr strange he's like
get the out of my way and they're
like oh what's up with this guy
you know he's like calling christine at
all hours of the night leaving dirty
messages and stuff and it's like it
would be like a very funny episode
but yeah in this movie i don't think
we're gonna get a lot of this guy and i
think it's really trying to just mislead
us and that's why they didn't show any
new footage of him or anything it was
it's all just like a to make you think
that he's the main bad guy in this i you
know what i think that there's a high
chance i talked to kevin feige earlier i
think that's an evil abed from community
ah
from now on i'm evil abid i made us all
black goatees out of felt i suggest you
put them on until you're able to grow
your own yeah this is evil op-ed it's
tough to do that because doctor strange
already has the goatee so with evil
doctor strange she should actually go t
right he should be clean-shaven no evil
hotbed has a goatee i know evil op-ed
does but if regular doctor strange has a
goatee that evil doctor strange should
have no goatee the bizarro version
off-screen off-screen producer john says
oh
did you hear that mt so off-screen
producer john just said that the the
statue we see of doctor strange in front
of the cinque santorum that one does not
have a goatee so maybe that's the evil
one and then of course we have zombie
strange or at the very least a zombie
looking strange and this very much looks
like doctor strange as a zombie
could very well be a reference to
episode 5 of what if that introduced the
zombie virus into the mcu and we did see
zombie strange in that episode but he
was killed off by the wasp and her
zombie eating ants so is this the same
zombie strange from that episode or a
different zombie strange or a different
being entirely what do you think i mean
you said it mt like that
that strange from that episode got eaten
by the ants which i don't know how the
ants don't turn into zombies i i guess
if you eat a zombie you don't turn into
a zombie zombie has to eat you i don't i
don't know but uh
yeah that one was wiped out so unless
that zombie was able because he was
magic able to like pull his body back
together
somehow maybe yeah i don't see how it
could be that exact same
one i think this is maybe the zombie
virus like leaking out of that
a multiverse because they're they're
clearly making what if cannon here and
they've always said it was canon but
they're clearly bringing it into the
mainstream movies uh i
i just don't think it's the same
zombie strange that we already saw die
i think it's a different one yeah i
don't think it's the same guy i think
that you know it could be a zombie
strange um and there there is a chance
that there this this could be tie into
those elements of um what if yeah so i
do have a feeling that this um doctor
strange here could actually be defender
strange that that doctor strange variant
that we don't really know a lot of that
wears a lot of all red and that is um
but specifically a doctor strange that
has like succumbed to um all the
darknesses of his variant selves that
he's absorbed because he is defending
the universe from
all of his variants so like over the
courses of a long time he's absorbed all
these of doctor strange variants which
is why all these black hands are like oh
these um
old corpses of black blackness as we saw
from the doctor strange episode of what
if uh he was absorbing all those dark
creatures into his body um to be part of
him so i think a similar thing is
happening here with um these arms that
were just they're probably just dark
versions of doctor strange that he's
absorbing and he probably absorbed too
much
and he's like out now i'm evil ducky
look at me
um doc ock
um which is funny because now he's
doctor now he's the doctor octopus but
yes i i gotta jump the gun but we also
have defender strange now in the tv spot
that air promoting the trailer online we
did get some completely different shots
including a look for steven that we'll
call defender strange he has a very
stylized red and blue uniform and no
cloak or eye of agamotto and a cleaner
haircut or possibly just hair pulled
back in a ponytail and more of a full
beard and his white hair streaks from
front to back and his uniform makes it
seem like he's part of a group possibly
the defenders which you know is a group
that doctor strange is very much linked
to in the comics and some previously
leaked toy art appeared to label this
version as defender strange like we said
before and the design of the costume
also looks very similar to the look of
the 2011 reboot of the defender's comic
art from marvel so how do we think that
this version of strange fits into the
overall narrative of this movie i mean i
like that idea empty that he this one
becomes the zombie which is very
interesting
it's very easy to set this one up to die
uh if he's you know running around the
multiverse trying to fix other strange's
problems i mean this is really weaving
into the kang storyline that i feel like
they're trying to tell too and maybe
they think it's easier for audiences to
understand that like yeah if you have
all these different
multiverses you're gonna have powerful
people that conflict with each other
throughout the multiverses um but yeah i
think this defender strange is here to
fix problems and he's he's well aware of
the illuminati is well aware of all
these problems and he's going to have to
catch our strange up to speed but i like
this idea that they could set him up to
take a bullet you know to take
to really get killed uh so that we don't
lose our our stephen strange maybe he
wants to take over our strangest spot
because our strange is bad and he wants
to come in and live in our universe
because it's so nice and lovely
that'd be interesting it'd be like yeah
that'd be like like you're just like hey
you your stuff is a lot more cooler than
mine your your sanctum's a lot more cool
yeah cooler books yeah and like uh your
universe is intact uh i'll take this one
i'll take that it's mine
for one million dollars no i think that
you know for with this version of doctor
strange like i was saying before i think
that this is a doctor strange that very
much went too far in trying to defend
his universe and this moment that we see
in the trailer of uh
defender strange holding his arm up and
like sort of like defending or
it's sort of like you know doing some
magic stuff around him i think that this
is the moment that may precede that
mountaintop moment at the end of the
trailer this is something that literally
just popped into my mind so i'm just
reselling this because i think that this
defender strange had a seat on the
council on the illuminati and then he
goes too far and like
has this darkness overtake him and then
he becomes this major threat that now
the illuminati have to deal with and
they're like hey doctor strange other
one come on
you're up but you didn't but you
really did
it was the version of you that we pissed
off uh we need your help killing yeah
it's like he used to be on our team he
knows all our secrets so
we have a problem
well one thing that's really interesting
about defender strange is in that 2011
run of the defenders that you brought up
where they kind of rebooted it in that
one they're go they're trying to stop
null who's like coming uh to rex wreck
some and we know we got like four
four coming up next uh and we know null
is gonna be at least mentioned in that
or very tangential to it and with all
this like kind of black inky stuff
happening and now you've got a little
bit of venom left behind in the mcu like
it would be interesting if they start
teasing null here
uh and maybe defender strange is like
out there trying to stop no stop
you violated the law and that's how
they're gonna start bringing in elements
of like
uh thor four because you know spider-man
far from home woe very nicely into this
storyline right we had a lot of doctor
strange in that and now we're like
following it up with variants you know
all the series that we had this uh last
year led into far from home which led
into this so it's like now they got to
start like leading into other things and
they've teased it with like loki getting
into kang and stuff and like what if
obviously bringing in all these elements
of the multiverse but now you know they
need to start bringing in setting up
future things and they could be setting
up null here i also think this is
another thing i think about this costume
that little simply has on the front you
know it's a nice little looking symbol
some angles it kind of looks like a bird
a red bird if you will
a phoenix if you will
get involved here
especially if you have professor x
hanging around
um i don't know what if what if defender
strange is is around with the uh
the phoenix force and this movie's just
going to be like
hey comic book nerds we're going to give
you everything you ever wanted now you
thought you thought you had it with no
way home sit back
sit back boys and girls and uh people
who don't identify with any gender we're
going to give it to you all baby
it's like you know what if you if you
guys you couldn't handle the phoenix
two times before here comes the third
one here comes the phoenix again with
phoenix trilogy baby charm here we go
let's try it again
a lot of people have been bringing up
the null comparison with that final shot
of the trailer and i think the writer of
venom writer donnie cates um said on
twitter that that is not null um
specifically so i know you weren't
saying that like you know that was no i
don't think they're going to show them
but like it could very much
still be teasing the darker elements of
the mcu that null is very much linked to
like i think that there is a no
association for sure
in this movie um in in some type of
tangential way so yeah i think that we
may be getting the the the beginnings of
explaining the no side of the darker
elements of the eye with this movie for
sure because it's all about darkness in
this movie so that is all the stranger
stranges that we have spotted do you
think the mcu will be left with its
standard strange by the end of the film
mr brandon i mean i teased my answer
already no i think i think we're gonna
lose the mcu's strange and one's going
to be left in its place
maybe a better strange uh maybe a wise
or strange but i think uh maybe a wong
maybe a wong as strange who knows maybe
two wongs make a strange i don't know
but i think that the mcu's og doctor
strange is not gonna make it to the end
of this movie and he's gonna get
replaced maybe sacrifice himself right
i don't think he's gonna be around
hey man like doctor strange is no
stranger to self-sacrifice no pun
intended um so he would definitely be
down to do it and i it would be a really
great lesson in
you can't really get away with
everything strange like there are
consequences and like that's a huge
thing in the doctor strange comics uh
like the bill coming due and like you
know
every spell having a price and so
pimping the ultimate price to like sort
of like peter did not at the ultimate
price but he sort of lost his life in
his in a way with no way home doctor
strange might have to do something
similar to that with his own life yeah
because the bill comes due like mordo
said so i like that idea but i do i do
think that he's gonna make it because
there has to be a doctor strange three
and a narrative thread that sort of
links the trilogy together well yeah i
think there will be a doctor strange
in place but it's not gonna be our
original strange that would be really
bananas but like i i think that like
he'll be okay but like he's gonna lose
something really close to him that's
gonna change him forever like christine
or
um something that's just gonna really or
maybe his magic like one of my favorite
um um story lines in doctor strange was
i think was from 2015 when um he loses
his magic and then um the this force
called the empirical comes in and tries
to take over the world while um there's
no magic and so doctor strange has to
and all the magic people have to band
together to try to reawaken the magic
within everyone within the world and so
i would love to see if all the magic in
the mcu just disappears for a little
while and like doctor strange like
having his own like iron man 3-esque
scenario where he's like looking for all
these relics in the world and trying to
find out the last ring out the magic of
the last bits of the relics of the world
and try to bring magic back because i
feel like that is
like where
he should be he should go because like
he's too he's too arrogant and he's too
powerful and like he needs to be knocked
down a peg by the end of this so i could
definitely see magic going at the end
sorry i have i go on weird tangents i
like it
i like it i watch that movie but that
sounds good
thanks bud
uh but before we continue our merch
partners over at the epic hero shop just
released two very very cool new mephisto
inspired designs you heard us here at
new rockstars appreciate about mephisto
a whole bunch and now you can rock him
on a t-shirt yourselves so grab one of
those or any of our other great merch
options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the amazing people that help
bring us big question to you people like
nap jitsu we know we don't know what
time of day you might be watching this
big question episode but if it's
mid-afternoon there's a good chance you
might be getting those 2pm sleepies i
get them all the time but that's because
i just never go to sleep and i'm a night
owl because i'm fighting crime that's
why my bones hurt all the time just
kidding i'm just old if you're looking
for a healthier energy option to help
you power through that afternoon
sleepiness nap jutsu has a natural time
released ingredients that help you stay
energized for hours without the crash
nap jitsu's natural supplements were
made by people who know how it feels to
be tired and busy their patented pended
formulas have natural ingredients like b
vitamins guarana and ginseng to give you
a boost of energy without the crash
later which because the crash sucks
screw the crash and each snapchat 2
product provides brain boosting
nootropics to unlock steady energy right
when you need it and that means you can
be at your peak performance all day long
and that jutsu supplements are packaged
into small packets so you can take them
wherever and whenever you might need an
energy boost so whether you need to
experience deeper sleep or unlock
immediate lasting energy each snapchat 2
product is designed to help you achieve
your optimal performance and remember
the smart rest more and the wise rest
better so rest up and level up with
napjitsu and for a limited time receive
30 off your first purchase when you go
to napjitsu.com
big question that is n a p
j i t s u dot com slash big question for
30 off your first purchase today bomba's
mission is simple make the most
comfortable clothes ever and match every
item sold with an equal item donated so
when you buy bombas you're also giving
to someone in need bamba's designed
their socks shirts and underwear to be
the clothes you can't wait to put on
every day everything they make is soft
seamless tagless and has super cozy feel
because of the super soft materials they
make them with there's a pair of socks
for everything you do from exercise to
work to just feeling cozy on the couch
bombus t-shirts are made with thoughtful
design features like invisible seams
soft fabrics and the perfect weight so
they hang
just right bomba's underwear has a
barely there feel with second skin
support that might make you feel like
you've forgotten they're even there in a
good way i don't know what the bad way
would be but this is in a good way and
did you know that socks underwear and
t-shirts are the three most requested
clothing items at homeless shelters
that's why bombus donates one for every
item you buy so far bombas customers
like you have helped donate over 50
million items of essential clothing go
to bombas.com bigquestion and get 20 off
any purchase that's b o m b a s com
bigquestion for 20 off bombast.com big
question now it is time for our bite
size question are you ready brandon
give me a bite yes
all right now in ant-man when they blow
up hank pym's lab why does it implode
instead of explode and this is from a
dog 27 on twitter thank you a dog yes
yes i mean it's been a while since the
original ant-man came out so you might
not remember and this this part happens
kind of fast so so we'll go through it
real quick in case you missed it if you
remember back in the events of the first
ant-man hank scott and hope are trying
to stop darren cross from copying pym
particles and selling them to evil
people like the 10 rings or even hydra
don't worry they're not what they used
to be they're they're doing some very
good stuff now uh yeah they're they're
rebranding it's fast
just kidding
so scott and the team they put together
a heist to steal the technology back but
you have to remember
it was never just a heist it was never
just a heist they wanted to make sure
that the tech is destroyed forever so
scott with the help of a few ants plants
explosive charges in the particle room
of the laboratory now they don't really
explain this when they're telling you
what they're going to do because this is
like the surprise that they blow it up
so it makes sense
you see them planting explosives but
you're like i have no idea these idea
why these explosives are there so
they're planning on where all the the
cross particles i guess is what we're
calling them where they're stored right
so when the building is successfully
cleared they make sure to say like hey
the building's cleared because this
isn't the dc eu where they kill uh they
kill people
no one's in here
no one's in here it's fine
so scott triggers the bomb and then boom
all the particles are released which
causes the big implosion
and remember cross's technology never
worked as well as hank pyms so it makes
sense that the building would implode
rather than just like neatly shrink down
you know just like old poor frank
imploded inside of that bathroom uh the
building implodes rather yeah just
shrink down from all the particles
because the particles don't work so
great dude frank's death in ant-man 1
was one of the most brutal
and gruesome things that the mcu has
ever done it still traumatizes eric voss
he can barely talk about it it is it is
literally disgusting and so gruesome and
like one of the like most cold-hearted
things that we've ever seen an mcu
villain do and like honestly darren
cross could have just sold that gun
he could just make that and just be like
hey it makes people it's a little goo
and there's no evidence he literally
just flushed the guy down the toilet
yeah and no one knew so geez empty
around around your 50th little lamb that
you've totally
grossly
shut down
you've lost all sense of what's real and
you don't care anymore
frank's just another bleeding lamp that
you gotta you gotta shrink seriously
just like he killed so many lambs that
he just lost his sense of humanity yeah
he's dead inside my size question number
two my friend how old is fenik shand and
does she age differently than other
people in the star wars universe this is
from mitch mark on discord you don't
want fedex hearing you ask how old she
is because then that's she's gonna kick
your butt
no one's ever gotten that answer because
they're dead
oh no because they're dead yeah
instantaneously so fenix shand appears
to be an ageless bounty hunter in the
star wars franchise though a lot of that
could probably be credited to the
genetics and skin care routine of
actress ming na wen uh looks looks great
ming now when is an ageless beauty i
like that woman is will just it's just
perfection i love her in every role that
she is cast her in everything disney i
love her she's a queen she's literally
the queen of disney princesses honestly
no one does it better than ming now win
sorry i just love her so much oh please
please she loves she loves the channel
she loves hearing it uh but is it
possible to figure out just how old the
bounty hunter is and why she never
really appears to age throughout the
series um as far as we can tell fenic is
a human and not some strange alien
species that never ages or ages very
slowly like grogu and the other yodas
out there
and while she does have some droid
modifications now those came fairly
later in life and wouldn't have
prevented any aging up until the point
where they go into her body what are you
talking about those are her natural abs
those are her natural mechanical abs
yeah like she's just that toned bro jeez
i would never cover up this beautiful
work
so fennek she first shows up in the star
wars universe around 19 bby uh and i
know all you know but just in case you
don't bby stands for before the battle
of yavin and is used in conjunction with
dance for a baby baby when i'm texting
my girlfriend on valentine's day just
gonna have a girlfriend
they use bby in conjunction with aby
which is after the battle of yavin and
this is a reference to the assault on
the death star which happens near yavin
4. you get it guys you get it since the
popular star wars universe lacks a
traditional yearly calendar yes it has
its own calendar don't at me i don't
want to get into the local calendar or
crc it's just
confusing i don't want to talk about it
anyways fenix shows up around 19 bby
just after the clone wars ended and at
that point she's already a fairly
skilled bounty hunter she's probably
like in her early to mid-20s maybe and
by the time of her appearance on
mandalorian it is 9 aby so it's been 28
years since she was first introduced
that would make her 48 when she showed
up in the mandalorian maybe 50 not bad
not bad at all now you might compare
that to boba fett when you look at boba
fett she looks pretty young and spry
right boba's looking rough
uh and boba fett in the mandalorian when
we first meet him he's about 41 or 42
because he's a clone of his father jango
but unlike the other clones he doesn't
appear to have like the quick aging gene
yeah i think django specifically had it
made so like his son just was a an
actual clone of him apart from his pay
which is considerable that demanded only
one thing
an unaltered clone for himself
curious isn't it jane goes like i want
one for myself don't give him the grow
juice make him normal but he's an exact
copy of me which is also very weird so
by 9 aby he'd be about 41-42 when we
first meet him in the mandalorian now
granted he spent some time in a sarlacc
pit and he spent a few years out in the
tatooine sun without much coverage so he
looks rough right he looks beat up
tamara morrison the actor who plays boba
fett he's 61 years old and ming na wen
is about 58 years old uh she just wears
her age a lot better than than boba fett
does yo ming now when i cannot say i'm
not like i i'm just i cannot get over
this woman's career that's what i just i
love herself agents of shield mulan
freaking star wars like bro she's taking
over all of the events of star wars
happen in such a small amount of time
star wars has existed in popular culture
for longer than the events of star wars
have taken place
almost in a way so it's kind of crazy
when you think about you're like oh
fennec shan how she would be so old but
she wouldn't be it's only been like 30
some odd years i mean it's really weird
when you look at the end of revenge of
the sith and the beginning of a new hope
and you see how much obi-wan has aged in
what is not that much time yeah i really
hope that they explain it like what's
with the events of
of obi-wan it's like oh and then the
force aged me to look like alex guinness
i mean it's the classic star trek
problem where the in the tos the
original series the klingon look very
normal they just have like kind of some
goatee and some hairy eyebrows and then
by the time of the next generation they
look completely different and
some went down all right now it is
time for our box of scraps
brandon what fashion choice from your
youth do you regret the most
this is tough so many bad fashion
choices to pick from uh i will say
you know i'm an older man uh during my
my younger years there was a fashion
trend going around you would wear a nice
white t-shirt and then you would get
this suede brown vest that you would
wear over your white t-shirt
just like an open vest just kind of
flowing
you know and that was that was a look
for a young cool dude especially growing
up in the south so i definitely rocked
that like suede vest a little too much
didn't appreciate it in my boot cut
jeans
um i probably would cringe uh now and
when i go back and you know see my mom
and she has old pictures up on the wall
of me and that awful suede vest i really
regret that choice
um but you know i really believed in it
at the time man we all be doing stuff
like that when we're kids man like we
all like to express ourselves in our own
way so it's like you know you know
i was trying something out i'm trying
out the best okay and it didn't work
you live and you learn i like it
um you know i had something very similar
because like growing up i specifically i
i primarily went to a lot of like
private schools a lot of christian
private schools and so like we had
uniforms and like so everyone looks the
same so you can't really do a lot to
stand out so i was like you know what
i'm wearing these blue polo shirts i
don't know why i'm talking every time i
go to my youth voice they talk like
mickey mouse anyway
like oh since we got all these blue polo
shirts i'm gonna pop my collar and
that's gonna be cool so i had popped a
freaking polo shirt caller for like a
couple of weeks and uh no girls
continued to talk to me i was still um
just uh just shoved in the corner that's
not too bad empty i like it
the problem with the pop collar is when
it's like flopping over and you can't
really see that it's like flopped over
like a little bunny rabbit ear or
something bro i would love if my collar
was just like a doctor strange's cape
you could just move and just like just
have a personality but no that's what i
did and i also here's another one um
when the remember when um when yolo was
a big thing oh yeah yolo first came out
um like i i remember hearing that
someone the first people hearing like
the drake song i was like oh man i gotta
make me some yellow hats so i made some
yellow hats on lids and i was one of the
first people wearing them hats regret it
because uh that got played out real
quick and i was like oh no but now i
look like an idiot with all these three
boxes of yolo hats in my room what am i
gonna do
i invested all my cash in yolo
we all do cringey stuff and some of you
watching may be in your cringy phase
right now look in the mirror look in the
mirror it was you think it was you
it was you all along but that is it for
this episode of big question thank you
to brandon for joining me on this
episode as always follow him at
grindenberric on twitter right now he is
a great man and he has amazing things to
say so following him there follow me at
mastertainment i'm less great but i say
a lot of weird so do that anyway
follow new rockstars here on youtube or
on all social media platforms and make
sure to hit that notification bell so
you can get notifications every time we
upload a video and if you want to
continue the nerd conversation our new
rockstars discord server is now open to
the public so if you are 18 years and
older and interested search for the new
rockstars discord server and join the
conversation because we would love to
have you we love all of our nerd family
my nerd babies come on down to discord
but yes thank you guys so much again for
watching we love you guys so much thank
you guys for spending time with us and
we will see you guys next time goodbye
bye
[Music]
you